The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
ERIC GRIMSON: Last
time, we started
talking about complexity.
And I want to quickly
remind you of what
we're doing, because we're
going to talk some more about
that today.
And when I say "complexity,"
it was the question of,
can we estimate the amount
of resources-- typically
time-- that we're going to need
to get an algorithm to solve
a problem of a particular size?
And we talked about
that both in terms
of estimating, how much
time is it going to take
and using it to go
the other direction
and think about how design
choices in an algorithm
have implications for
the cost that's going
to be associated with that.
So we introduced
the idea of what
we call big O notation,
orders of growth,
a way of measuring complexity.
And we started talking
about different classes
of algorithms.
So today, I'm going to quickly
recap those basic ideas.
And what we're
going to do is we're
going to see examples of
standard classes of algorithms
with the idea that
you're going to want
to begin to recognize when an
algorithm is in that class.
So very quick recap-- I've
already said part of this.
We want to have a mechanism,
a method for being
able to estimate
or reason about,
how much time do we think
an algorithm's going
to take to solve a problem
of a particular size.
And especially as we increase
the size of the input
to the algorithm,
what does that do
in terms of the increase in the
amount of time that we need?
Some ways, we don't care
about exact versions.
In a second, we're going to
see the definition of this.
But what we care about
is that notion of,
how does it grow as we
increase the problem size.
And what we're going
to focus in going,
if you like, in the forward
direction-- as I said,
a lot of the
interest is actually
thinking about what
you might think
of as the backwards
or reverse direction.
How does a choice in algorithm
design impact efficiency
of the algorithm?
And really, what
we want you to do
is to begin to recognize
standard patterns,
that, if you make a
particular choice,
this fits in a class of
algorithms you've seen before.
And I know, in essence, how
much time-- what the cost is
going to be as I do that.
All right, so just to recap,
as it says on the top,
we talked about
orders of growth.
And the idea is, we want to be
able to evaluate a program's
efficiency when the
input is very big.
We talked about timing
things just with a timer.
We suggested that,
unfortunately,
conflates the algorithm
with the implementation
with the particular machine.
We want to get rid
of those latter two
and just focus on the algorithm.
So we're going to talk
about counting operations,
but in a very general sense.
So we're going to
express what we
call the growth of
the program's runtime
as the input size
grows very large.
And because we're
only interested
not in the exact
number, but in, if you
like, the growth of
that, we're going
to focus on putting
an upper bound
on the growth, an expression
that grows at least as
fast as what the cost
of the algorithm is.
Now, you could just cheat and
pick a really big upper bound.
That doesn't help us very much.
So in general, we're
going to try and use
as tight an upper
bound as we can.
What's the class of
algorithm it falls in?
But as we've seen before, we
care about the order of growth,
not being exact.
So if something grows
as 2 to the n plus 5n,
I don't care about the 5n.
Because when n gets
big, that 2 to the n
is the really big factor.
And therefore we're going to
look at the largest factors
when we think about that.
We've seen some examples.
We're going to do a
bunch more examples
today to fill those in.
One of the things
that we want to now do
is say, with that
idea in mind, there
are classes of
complexity of algorithms.
So in some sense, the best
ones are way up here, O of 1,
order 1, constant.
It says cost doesn't change as
I change the size of the input.
That's great.
It's always going
to be the same cost.
Order log n says the cost
grows logarithmically
with the size of the input.
It's a slow growth, and
I'm going to remind you
of that in a second.
We saw lots of examples of
linear running time-- we're
going to see a few more today--
what we call log-linear,
polynomial, and exponential.
And the thing I
want to remind you
is that, ideally--
whoops, sorry--
we'd like our
algorithms to be as
close to the top of this
categorization as we can.
This is actually described in
increasing order of complexity.
Something that takes
the same amount of time
no matter how big the input
is, unless that amount of time
is a couple of centuries, seems
like a really good algorithm
to have.
Something that grows
linearly is not bad.
Something that grows, as we've
seen down here, exponentially
tends to say, this is
going to be painful.
And in fact, you can
see that graphically.
I'll just remind you here.
Something that's constant
says, if I draw out
the amount of time it
takes as a function
of the size of the
input, it doesn't change.
Logarithmic glows-- gah,
sorry-- grows very slowly.
Linear will grow,
obviously, in a linear way.
And I actually
misspoke last time.
I know it's rare for a professor
to ever admit they misspeak,
but I did.
Because I said linear is, if you
double the size of the input,
it's going to double the
amount of time it takes.
Actually, that's an
incorrect statement.
Really, what I
should have said was,
the increment-- if I go
from, say, 10 to 100,
the increase in time-- is going
to be the same as the increment
if I go from 100 to 1,000.
Might be more than
double depending
on what the constant is.
But that growth is linear.
If you want to think of
it, take the derivative
of time with respect
to input size.
It's just going
to be a constant.
It's not going to change within.
And of course, when
we get down to here,
things like exponential,
it grows really fast.
And just as a last
recap, again, I
want to be towards
the top of that.
There was my little
chart just showing you
things that grow constant, log,
linear, log-linear, quadratic,
and exponential.
If I go from n of 10, to
100, to 1,000, to a million,
you see why I want to be
at the top of that chart.
Something up here that
grows logarithmically,
the amount of time grows very
slowly as I increase the input.
Down here, well, like
it says, good luck.
It's going to grow
up really quickly
as I move up in that scale.
I want to be at the top
of this chart if I can.
OK, with that in mind,
when I'm going to do today
is show you examples filling
in most of this chart.
We've already seen
some examples.
We've seen examples of linear.
We've seen examples
of quadratic.
I'm going to just
remind you of those.
What I want to do
is show you how
you can begin to recognize
a choice of an algorithm
in terms of where it lies.
So algorithms that are
constant complexity,
they're kind of boring.
They tend to be pretty simple.
Because this says,
this code is going
to run in, basically, the same
amount of time independent
of the size of the input.
Now, notice the
bottom thing here.
It doesn't say you
can't-- blah, try again.
It doesn't say you couldn't
have a loop or a recursive call.
You could, it's just that that
loop cannot depend on the size
of the input.
So there aren't many
interesting algorithms here.
We're going to see pieces
of code that fit into this
when we do our analysis.
But something that's
constant in complexity
says, independent of
the size of the input.
All right, a little more
interesting-- not a little,
a lot more interesting--
are algorithms
that are logarithmic
in their complexity.
So they're going to
grow with the logarithm
of the size of the input.
You saw an example much
earlier in the term when Ana
showed you bisection search.
It was searching for a number
with a particular property.
I want to show you
another example,
both to let you recognize
the form of the algorithm,
but especially, to show you how
we can reason about the growth.
And that's another trick
called binary search
or, again, it's a version
of bisection search.
Suppose I give you a list,
a list of numbers, integers.
And I want to know if
a particular element is
in that list.
We saw, last time, you could
just walk down the list, just
iterate through the entire list
looking to see if it's there.
In the worst case, which
is what we worry about,
it's going to be linear.
You're going to have to look
at every element in the list
till you get to the end.
So complexity was
linear in that case.
And then we said, suppose we
know that the list is sorted.
It's ordered from
smallest to largest.
And we saw, a simple
algorithm says, again,
walk down the list checking
to see if it's there.
But when you get to an element
that's bigger than the thing
you're looking at,
you can just stop.
There's no reason to look
at the rest of the list.
They've all got to be
bigger than the thing you're
searching for.
Practically, in
the average case,
that's going to be
faster than just looking
at an unsorted list.
But the complexity
is still linear.
Because in the
worst case, I've got
to go all the way
through the list
before I deduce that
the thing is not there.
OK, so even sequential
search in an ordered list
is still linear.
Can we do better?
And the answer is, sure.
So here's how we do better.
I'm going to take that list.
I'm going to assume it's sorted.
And I'm going to pick an index
that divides the list in half,
just pick the
midpoint in the list.
And I'm going to
check that value.
I'm going to ask, is the element
in the list at that point
the thing I'm looking for?
If it is, great, I'm done.
If I'm not that lucky,
I'm then going to ask,
is it larger or smaller than
the thing I'm looking for?
And based on that,
I'm either going
to search the front half or
the back half of the list.
Ooh, that's nice, OK?
Because if you think about
it, in something that was just
a linear algorithm,
at each step,
I reduced the size
the problem by 1.
I went from a problem of size n
to a problem of size n minus 1
to a problem of size n minus 2.
Here, I'm taking a
problem of size n.
I'm reducing it to
n/2 in one step,
because I can throw
half the list away.
So this is a version
of divide and conquer,
things we've seen before.
I'm breaking it down
into smaller versions
of the problem.
So let's look at that.
And then, let's write some code.
And then, let's analyze it.
So suppose I have a list
of size n, all right?
There are n elements in there.
I'm going to look at
the middle one, say,
is it the thing I'm looking for.
If it's not, is it
bigger than or less
than the thing I'm looking for?
And in this case, let's
assume that, in fact,
the thing I'm looking for is
smaller than that element.
Great.
I'm going to throw
away half the list.
Now I only have to look at
the lower half of the list.
I'll do the same thing.
I'll look at the element
in the middle here.
And I'll say, is it the
thing I'm looking for?
If not, is it bigger
than or smaller
than the thing I'm looking for?
OK, and I'm down
to n/2 elements.
And after I do that, I throw
away half the list again.
In this case, I'm assuming
that the thing I'm looking for
is bigger than
that middle point.
Until I find it,
at each step, I'm
looking at the middle element.
And I'm either throwing
away the left half
or the right half of that list.
So after i steps, I'm down to a
list of size n over 2 to the i.
Now, what's the worst case?
The worst case is the
element's not in the list.
I'm going to have
to keep doing this
until I get down to just
a list of one element.
And at that point, if it's
not the thing I'm looking for,
I know I'm done, and I can stop.
Different pattern-- notice
how I'm cutting down
the size of the problem by 2.
So I can ask, before we
look at the code, what's
the complexity of this?
How many steps do I have to
go through in the worst case?
And I know I'm going to be
done looking at the list when
n over 2 to the i is
equal to 1, meaning
there's only one element left
that I'm still looking at.
And I can solve that.
It says I'm going to have
to take, at most, i equal
to log n steps, all right?
So logarithmically,
I'm cutting this down.
And so the complexity
of the recursion--
we haven't talked
about the code yet,
but in terms of
the number of steps
I have to do in
the worst case-- is
just logarithmic in
the length of the list.
That's nice.
It's a lot better than looking
at everything inside the list.
And in fact, you
can see it, right?
I don't look at everything
inside the list here.
I'm throwing half the
things away at a time.
OK, so let's look at
some code to do that.
Bisection search-- I'm going
to give it a list of numbers.
I'm going to give it
something I'm looking for.
We can walk through this code.
Hopefully it's
something that you're
going to be able to
recognize pretty clearly.
It says if the list is
empty, there's nothing there,
the thing I'm looking for
can't be there, I return False.
If there's exactly one
element in the list,
then I just check it.
If that thing's the thing
I'm looking for, return True.
Otherwise, return False.
So I'm just going to
return the value there.
Otherwise, find the midpoint--
notice the integer division
here-- find the midpoint
in that list and check it.
In particular, say, if
the thing at the midpoint
is bigger than the
thing I'm looking for,
then I'm going to
return a recursive call
to this function only looking
at the first half of the list.
I'm just slicing into it.
Otherwise, I'll
do the same thing
on the second half of the list.
Nice, this is implementing
exactly what I said.
We could actually try it.
I'll do that in a
second if I remember.
But let's think about
complexity here.
That's constant, right?
Doesn't depend on
the size of the list.
That's constant, doesn't
depend on the size of the list.
That's consonant.
Sounds good.
And what about that?
Well, it looks like it
should be constant, right,
other than the number of times
I have to go through there.
Remember, I know I'm going
to have order log n recursive
calls.
I'm looking at what's
the cost to set it up.
It looks like it
should be constant.
So does that.
But I'm going to claim it's not.
Anybody see why it's not?
You can look at the slides
you've already printed out.
Right there-- I'm actually
copying the list, all right?
When I slice into
the list like that,
it makes a copy of the list.
Oh, crud.
I was about to say
something different,
but I won't, because this is
going to cost me a little bit
as I think about the work.
So let's look at that a
little more carefully.
I've got order log
n search calls.
We just deduced that.
I've just repeated
it here, right?
On each call, I'm reducing
the size of the list in half.
So it goes from n, to n/2,
to n/4, to n/8, to n/16.
I'll be done, in
the worst case, when
I get down to having
only a list of size 1.
That takes a log n steps,
because n over 2 to the log n
is n/n, which is 1.
But to set up the
search for each cell,
I've got to copy the list.
And the list starts out n
long, so in principle, I've
got order n work to do to
set up the recursive call.
And so by the things
we saw last time,
I got order log n for the number
of recursive calls times order
n work inside of each call.
And that's order n log n.
So it's not what I wanted.
Now, if you're thinking
about this carefully,
you'll realize, on each
step, I'm not actually
copying the whole list.
I'm copying half the list, and
then, a quarter of the list,
and then, an eighth of the list.
So if I was actually
really careful-- I'm not
going to do the math here--
and in fact, what we'll see--
and if you like, in your copious
spare time, you can go off
and work this through--
what you'll discover
is that you're actually doing
order n work to do the copying.
But that's still a
problem, because then, I've
got something that's
order n plus log n.
And the n is going to dominate,
so this is still linear.
Sounds like I led you
down a primrose path here.
Can we fix this?
Sure.
Because we could
do the following.
We could say, when I want
to look at that list,
do I need to copy everything?
What about if,
instead, I said, here's
the beginning and
the end of the list.
When I test the middle, I'll
move one of the pointers
to the middle of the list.
When I test the middle again,
I'll move another pointer in.
So in other words, I
can test the middle.
And based on that,
I could say, I only
need to search this
part of the list.
Just keep track of that point
and that point in the list.
And when I test the
middle again, same idea.
Now I'm not actually
copying the list,
I am simply keeping
track of, where
are the pieces of the
list that bound my search.
Ha, all right?
I'm still reducing the size of
the problem by a factor of 2
at each step.
That's great.
All I'd need to do now,
though, is just keep
track of which portion of
the list I'm searching.
I'm going to avoid
copying the list.
So the number of
recursive calls,
again, will be logarithmic.
Let's see if that
actually fixes my problem.
A little bit of code, not
as bad as it looks-- I've
got an internal function here
that I'm going to come back to.
But let's look at what
happens in this case.
I'm going to say, again,
if there's nothing
in the list, just return False.
Element can't possibly be there.
Otherwise, call this
function with the list,
the element for
whom I'm searching,
and the beginning and end of
the list-- so 0 at one end,
length of n l minus
1 at the other end.
It's just that idea
of, I'm keeping
track of the two pieces, OK?
Now let's look at
what this does.
It says, here's the
low part of the list,
the high part of the list.
Initially, it's 0 and
length of list minus 1.
It says, if they are the
same, oh cool, then I've
got a list of length 1.
Just test to see if it's
the thing I'm looking for.
If they're not,
find the midpoint.
And the midpoint's
just the average of low
plus high, integer
division by 2.
Think about it.
If it's 0 and n,
midpoint is n/2.
But if it's, for example,
n/2 and n, midpoint is 3/4 n.
So that mid picks
the middle point.
If it's the thing I'm
looking for, great, I'm done.
Otherwise, check to see,
is the thing at the middle
bigger than or less than
the thing I'm looking for.
And based on that-- I'm going
to skip this one for a second--
I'm either going to
search everything
from the low point up
to the middle point
or from the middle point
up to the high point.
And the last piece
here is, if, in fact,
the low point and the
middle point are the same,
I've got a list of size 1.
There's nothing left to do.
I'm done.
OK, I know it's a lot of code.
I would invite you just
to walk through it.
But I want to take you
back again to just, simply,
this point and say,
here's what we're doing.
We're starting off with pointers
at the beginning and end
of the list.
We're testing the middle point.
And based on that,
we're giving a call
where, now, the pointer is to
the beginning and the middle
of the list, simply
passing it down,
and same as I go through
all of these pieces.
So that code now gives
me what I'd like.
Because here, in the
previous case, I had a cost.
The cost was to copy the list.
In this case, it's constant.
Because what am I doing?
I'm passing in three values.
And what does it take
to compute those values?
It's a constant amount of
work, because I'm simply
computing mid right there, just
with an arithmetic operation.
And that means
order log n steps,
because I keep reducing
the problem in half.
And the cost at each
point is constant.
And this is, as a consequence,
a really nice example
of a logarithmic
complexity function.
Now, if you think about it, I'm
cheating slightly-- second time
today.
Because we said we really don't
care about the implementation.
We want to get a sense of the
complexity of the algorithm.
And that's generally true.
But here is a place in which
the implementation actually has
an impact on that complexity.
And I want to be conscious of
that as I make these decisions.
But again, logarithmic
in terms of number
of steps, constant
work for each step,
because I'm just
passing in values.
And as a consequence, the
overall algorithm is log.
Notice one other thing.
I said I want you to see
characteristics of algorithms
that tell you something
about the complexity
of that algorithm.
Something that's iterative and
reduces the problem by size 1
each time, from n, to n minus
1, to n minus 2-- linear.
Something that reduces
the size of the problem
in half, or in thirds, or
in quarters each time--
logarithmic,
generally, unless I've
got a hidden cost somewhere.
Here's another
little example just
to give you a sense of log.
I want to convert an
integer to a string.
I know I can just
call str() on it.
But how might we do that
inside of the machine?
Well, here's a nice
little algorithm for it.
I'm going to set up
something I call digits.
It's just a string
of all the digits.
If the thing I'm
trying to convert is 0,
I just return the string "0".
Otherwise, let's run
through a little loop
where I take that
integer divided
by 10, the remainder of that.
What is that?
Oh, that's the zeroth or the
1-order, the first order bit.
And I'm going to index
into digits to find that.
And I'm going to add it on to
a string that I'm [INAUDIBLE].
And I'll divide i by 10.
So this says,
given an integer, I
want to convert it to a string.
I divide the integer by
10, take the remainder.
That gives me the zeroth, or
if you like, the ones element.
I index into the
string, and I record it.
And then I add it to what
I get by dividing i by 10
and doing the same thing.
So I'll just walk down
each of the digits,
converting it into a string.
What I care about is the
order of growth here.
This is all constant.
All I want to worry about
here is, how many times
do I go through the loop.
And inside of the loop,
this is just constant.
It doesn't depend on
the size of the integer.
So how many times do
I go through the loop?
Well, how many times
can I divide i by 10?
And that's log of i, right?
So it's not i itself.
It's not the size
of the integer.
It's the number of
digits in the integer.
And here's another
nice example of log.
I'll point you,
again, right here.
I'm reducing the
size of the problem
by a constant
factor-- in this case,
by 10-- each time--
nice characteristic
of a logarithmic algorithm.
OK, we've got constant.
We've got log.
What about linear?
We saw it last time, right?
Something like searching
a list in sequence
was an example of
something that was linear.
In fact, most of the
examples we saw last time
were things with
iterative loops.
So for example, fact, written
intuitively-- factorial,
right-- n times n
minus 1 times n minus 2
all the way down to 1.
I set product to 1.
I go for a loop where i
goes from 1 up to n minus 1,
or just below n minus
1-- incrementally
multiplying product by i and
restoring that back away.
Again, we know that this loop
here-- how many times do I
go through it?
I go through it n times.
The cost inside the loop, there
are three steps, changing i,
I'm multiplying product times
i, I'm storing that value back
in product.
And as we saw, that
constant doesn't matter.
This is linear.
So n times around the loop,
constant cost each time-- order
n.
What about recursive?
I could write fact recursively.
I actually prefer
it this way, right?
If n is less than or
equal to 1, return 1.
Otherwise, multiply
n by whatever I get
by calling this on n minus 1.
The cost inside the
loop is just constant.
I'm doing one subtraction,
one multiplication.
How many times I go through it?
Again, n times, because I've
got to go from n to n minus 1
to n minus 2.
So again, this is linear.
Now, if you were
to time it, you'd
probably see a difference.
My guess is-- I'm sure
Professor Guttag will correct me
if I get it wrong-- is that
the factorial one probably
takes a little more
time, because you've
got to set up the frame
for the recursive call.
But in terms of what we care
about, they're the same.
They're both linear.
They're order n.
And so interestingly, both
iterative and recursive
factorial have same
order of growth.
Again, I want you to
notice, what's the key here.
Reducing the size of the problem
by 1 is indicative, generally,
of something that's going
to have linear growth.
I say in general.
If it's a loop inside
of a loop, as we saw,
it might be a little bigger.
But this is generally linear.
Constant, log, linear,
log-linear-- that is,
n log n-- we're going
to see this next time.
I'm certainly going
to push it ahead.
It invites you to come back
on Wednesday and see this.
It's actually something that's
a really powerful algorithm.
It's going to be really useful.
We're going to look
at something called
merge sort, which is a very
common sorting algorithm
and has that property
of being log-linear.
So we'll come back
to this next time.
How about polynomial?
Well, we saw this
last time as well.
This commonly occurs
when we have nested loops
or where we have nested
recursive function
calls-- nested loop meaning
I'm looping over some variable,
and inside of there,
I've got another loop.
And what we saw
is the outer loop,
if it's a standard iterative
thing, will be linear.
But inside of the loop, I'm
doing a linear amount of work
each time.
So it becomes n times
n, so order n squared.
OK, exponential-- these
are things-- sorry,
yes, I did that right.
I'm going to go back to it.
Exponential-- these are things
that we'd like to stay away
from, but sometimes, we can't.
And a common
characteristic here is
when we've got a
recursive function
where there's more
than one recursive
call inside the problem.
Remember Towers of Hanoi, that
wonderful demonstration I did.
I was tempted to bring it
back, because it's always
fun to get a little bit
of applause when I do it.
But I won't do it this time.
But remember, we
looked at that problem
of solving the Towers of Hanoi.
How do I move a stack of size
n of different-sized disks
from one peg to another
where I can only
move the top disk
onto another one
and I can't cover
up a smaller disk?
Want to remind
you, we saw, there
was a wonderful recursive
solution to that.
It said, move a stack of size
n minus 1 onto the spare peg.
Move the bottom one.
And then, move that stack
over onto the thing you
were headed towards, OK?
What's the complexity of that?
Well, I'm going to show you a
trick for figuring that out.
It's called a
recurrence relation
for a very deliberate reason.
But it'll give us
a little, handy way
to think about, what's
the order of growth here.
So I'm going to let t sub
n denote the time it takes
to move a tower of size n.
And I want to get
an expression for,
how much time is
that going to take.
What do I know?
I know that's 2 times t
to the n minus 1, right?
I've got to move a stack of
size 1 less onto the spare peg,
and then, 1 to move that
bottom thing over, and then,
whatever it takes me to move
a stack of size n minus 1
over to that peg.
OK, so how does that help me?
Well, let's play the same game.
What's t of n minus 1?
Oh, that's 2t of
n minus 2 plus 1.
I'm just substituting in.
I'm using exactly the
same relationship here.
All right, let's just do
a little math on that.
That's 4t to the n
minus 2 plus 2 plus 1.
And you're still
going, OK, who cares.
Well, let's do the same
thing one more time.
t of n minus 2-- that's
2t of n minus 3 plus 1.
Oh, see the pattern?
You can start to see
it emerge here, right?
Each time I reduce this, I'm
adding another power of 2,
and I'm increasing the
coefficient out front.
And so, in fact, after k
steps, I'll have 1 plus 2
plus 4 all the way up
to 2 to the k minus 1
plus 2 to the k times
t sub n minus k.
Hopefully you can see
it if you just look.
This expression is capturing
all of those up there.
I'm just pulling
it out each time.
When am I done?
When this is size 0,
when k is equal to n.
And so that's when I
get that expression.
If this is going by too fast,
just walk it through yourself
later on.
But I'm literally just
using this expression
to do the reduction
until I see the pattern.
All right, what's that?
Well, if your Course 18
major, you've seen it before.
If you haven't, here's
a nice, little trick.
Let me let a equal that sum,
2 to the n minus 1 plus 2
to the n minus 2 all
the way down to 1.
Let me multiply both the
left and the right side by 2.
That gives me, 2a is equal
to 2 to the n plus 2 to the n
minus 1 all the way down to 2.
I'm just taking
each of the terms
and multiplying them by 2.
Now subtract this from that.
And then on the left
side, you get a.
And on the right side,
you get that term.
These all cancel out minus
1-- geometric series, cool.
So that sum is just
2 to the n minus 1.
And if I plug that
back in there,
ah, I've got my order of
growth, exponential, 2 to the n.
OK, I was a
math/physics undergrad.
I like these kinds of things.
But I wanted you
to see how we can
reason through it, because this
is letting us see the growth.
What I want you to
pull away from this is,
notice the characteristic.
In Towers of Hanoi--
we're going to do
another example in a
second-- the characteristic
was, at the recursive
step, I had not one,
but two recursive calls.
And that is characteristic
of something
with exponential growth, which
I just saw here, 2 to the n.
That, by the way,
I'll remind you
of the story of Towers of--
Towers of Hanoi, right?
When the priests in that temple
move the entire stack from one
peg to another, we all reach
nirvana, and the world ends.
n is equal to 64 here.
Go figure out what
2 to the 64 is.
And if you're doing one move
per second, which they will,
I think we're certainly
going to be here a while
before the universe ends
and we reach nirvana,
probably several times over.
AUDIENCE: I thought we
were already in nirvana.
ERIC GRIMSON: We are in
nirvana, we're at MIT.
You're right, John.
But we're worrying about
the rest of the world.
So, OK, we'll keep moving on.
Nirvana will be next week
when they do the quiz, John.
So we'll keep moving quickly.
All right.
I want to show you
one more example.
It's a cool problem
from math, but mostly
to see that characteristic
of exponential growth.
And then we're going to
pull all of this together.
This is something
called the power set.
So if I have a set
of things-- well,
let's assume I have a set of
integers-- with no repeats--
so 1 through n, 1, 2,
3, 4, for example--
I want to generate
the collection
of all possible subsets--
so subset with no elements,
with one element, with two
elements, with three amounts,
all the way up to n elements.
So for example, if my
set is 1 through 4,
then the power set
would be the empty set
with no elements in it, all of
the instances with one element,
all of them with two,
all of them with three,
and all of them with four.
I'd like to write
code to generate this.
It's actually handy problem in
number theory or in set theory.
By the way, the
order doesn't matter.
I could do it this way, but this
would be a perfectly reasonable
way of generating it as well.
And I'm going to come
back to that in a second
as we think about solving this.
The question is, how would I
go about finding all of these.
I'm going to use-- well,
we could stop and say,
you could imagine writing
a big iterative loop.
You start with n, and you
decide, do I include it or not.
And then you go to n minus 1.
Do I include it or not?
And you could think about
writing a big loop that
would generate all
of these-- actually,
a bunch of nested loops.
But there's a nice
recursive solution.
And I want to encourage
you to think that way.
So here's the way
I'm going to do it.
What did we do when we said
we want to think recursively?
We say, let's assume we can
solve a smaller size problem.
If I want to generate the
power set of all the integers
from 1 to n, I'm
going to assume that I
can generate the power set of
integers from 1 to n minus 1.
If I have that solution, then
I can construct the solution
to the bigger problem
really easily.
Wow.
Well, all of the
things that were
in that solution to
the smaller problem
have to be part of the
solution to the bigger problem.
They're all subsets of
1 to n, because they're
all subsets of 1 to n minus 1.
So I'm going to
add all those in.
And then I'm going to say,
let's take each one of those
and add n to each
of those subsets.
Because that gives me all
the rest of the solutions.
I've got all the ways to
find solutions without n.
I get all the ways to
find solutions with n.
That may sound like a
lot of gobbledygook,
but let me show you the example.
There is the power
set of the empty set.
It's just the empty set.
Get the power set of
1, I include that,
and I include a version
of everything there with 1
added to it.
There's the power set of 1.
Now, given that, how do
I get the power set of 2?
Well, both of those are
certainly things I want.
And for each one of
them, let me just add 2.
And if you look at
that, right, that's
the set of all ways of getting
nothing, 1, 2, or both of them.
And you get the idea.
Now, having that solution, I
can get the solution for 3,
because all of those
have to belong.
And I simply add 3
to each one of those.
Oh, that's cool, right?
All right, you don't have to be
a math geek to admit it's cool.
It is kind of cool.
Because it says,
gee, got a solution
to the smaller problem.
Generating the next
piece is a natural step.
And you can also see,
the size of that set's
doubling each time.
Because you get to 4, I'm
going to add everything
in to all of those pieces--
really nice recursive
description.
Let's write some code.
So I'll also hand it out to
you, but here's the code.
And I'm going to walk
through it carefully.
And then we're
going to analyze it.
But it's actually, for me,
a beautiful piece of code.
I did not write it,
by the way, John did.
But it's a beautiful
piece of code.
I want to generate all
the subsets with a power
set of some list of elements.
Here's how I'm going to do it.
I'm going to set up some
internal variable called
res, OK?
And then, what am I going to do?
Actually, I don't know
why I put res in there.
I don't need it.
But we'll come back to that.
If the list is empty,
length of the list is 0,
I'm going to just
return that solution.
And this is not a typo.
What is that funky thing there?
It is a list of one
element, which is
the empty list, which I need.
Because the solution
in this case
is a set with nothing in it.
So there is the thing I
return in the base case.
Otherwise, what do I do?
I take all the elements of
the list except the last one,
and I call it recursively.
I generate all of
the subsets of that.
Perfect, so I'm going
to call that smaller.
I then take the last
element, and I make a list
of just the last element.
And what did I say I need to do?
I need all of these guys,
plus I need all of them
where I add that
element in-- oh, nice.
I'll set up new as
a variable here.
And I'll loop over
all of the elements
from the smaller problem,
where I basically
add that list to that list.
And I put it into new.
That's simply taking all
of the solutions of subsets
of up to n minus 1 and creating
a new set of subsets where n is
included in every one of them.
And now I take this,
and I take that.
I append them-- or
concatenate them, rather.
I should say "append them"--
concatenate them together
and return them.
That's a crisp piece of code.
And I'm sorry, John, I have no
idea why I put res up there.
I don't think I need that
anywhere in this code.
And I won't blame it on John.
It was my recopying of the code.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] .
ERIC GRIMSON: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: Maybe.
ERIC GRIMSON: Maybe, right.
Look, I know I'm flaming at you.
I get to do it.
I'm tenured, as I've said
multiple times in this course.
That's a cool piece of code.
Imagine trying to write it
with a bunch of loops iterating
over indices.
Good luck.
You can do it.
Maybe it'll be on the quiz.
Actually, no, it won't.
That's way too hard to ask.
But it's a cool piece of
code, because I can look at it
and say, what's the solution,
solve the smaller problem,
and then, given
that, take every one
of the things in
that smaller problem,
add that element into it, and
put the two pieces together.
Wonderful.
OK, with that in mind, let's
see if we can figure out
the complexity of this.
Up here, that's constant.
That's OK.
Right there, I've got
the recursive call.
So I know, first of
all, that this is going
to call itself n times, right?
Because each stage reduces
the size of the problem by 1.
So if I'm trying to
get the power set of n,
I'm going to have to
do it to get n minus 1,
and then, n minus 2.
So I know the recursion of
genSubsets() to genSubsets().
This is going to
go around n times.
That's not so bad.
But right down here,
I've got to figure out,
what's the cost of
this, all right?
This is constant.
That's setting up as constant.
That's constant.
But there, I've
got another loop.
And the loop depends
on how big smaller is.
And "smaller's" a bad choice
of term here, because it's
going to grow on me.
But let's think about it.
By the way, I'm assuming
append is constant time,
which, generally, it is.
The time I need to
solve this problem
includes the time to
solve the smaller problem.
That recursive call, I know
that's going to be linear.
But I also need
the time it takes
to make the copy of all the
things in that smaller version.
So how big is that?
Oh, crud number two-- number
of things in the power set
grows as a factor of 2, right?
If I've got something of,
you know, 1 through 3,
I've got all the things
with nothing in it,
all the things with one
in it, all the things
with two things in it, all the
things with three things in it.
That's 8.
And each time around, I'm
doubling the size of it.
So for a set of size k,
there are 2 the k cases.
And that says that
this loop right here
is going to be
growing exponentially.
Because I've got to go
down that entire list
to find all of the pieces.
So what's the
overall complexity?
I'm going to play the same game.
Let's let t sub n
capture the time it takes
to solve a problem of size n.
Just temporarily,
I'm going to let
s sub n denote the size of the
solution for a problem of size
n.
How big is that thing, smaller?
And what do I know?
The amount of time it takes me
to solve the problem of size n
is the amount of time it
takes me to solve the slightly
smaller problem-- that's
the recursive call
to genSubsets()-- plus the
amount of time it takes me
to run over that loop looking
at everything in smaller
and adding in a new version,
plus some constant c,
which is just the number
of constant operations,
the constant steps
inside that loop, OK?
And if I go back to it,
t sub n is the cost here.
t sub n minus 1
is the cost there.
s sub n is the size of this.
And then I've got,
one, two, three, four,
five constant steps.
So c is probably 5 in this case.
So what can I say?
There's the relationship.
Because I know s of n minus
1 is 2 to the n minus 1.
There are 2 to the n minus
1 elements inside of that.
How do I deal with this?
Let's play the same game.
What's t sub n minus 1?
That's t of n minus 2 plus
2 to the n minus 2 plus c.
And I could keep doing this.
You can see what the
pattern's going to look like.
I'm going to have k
times c constant steps.
For each reduction, I'm going
to get another power of 2.
And I'm going to reduce this
overall term, after k steps,
to t the n minus k.
When am I done?
When that's down to
something of size 0.
And there's the expression.
And what you can
see is what I wanted
you to see, order n-- or
sorry, order 2 to the n--
is exponential in the
size of the problem.
What's the characteristic?
Something that has a
recursive call-- sorry,
multiple recursive
calls at each step--
is likely to lead
to exponential.
But that can also
be buried inside
of how I grow the
size of the problem.
And that was the case here.
There's only one recursive
call, but that loop
grows in size each time around.
So the complexity
is exponential.
I'm going to pull this together.
I said one of the things I'd
like to start to recognize
is, what are the characteristics
of a choice in algorithm that
leads to a particular
complexity class.
And you now have some of them.
If the code doesn't depend
on the size of the problem,
that's constant.
And in fact, we've
been using that as we
look at pieces of the code.
If we can reduce the problem--
I said, in this case--
by half each time, by
some constant factor,
from n, to n/2, to
n/4, to n/8, that
tends to be characteristic--
unless there's
a hidden cost somewhere else--
of a logarithmic algorithm.
These are really nice.
Simple things that reduce
the size of the problem
by 1 at each step--
an iterative call
that goes from n, to n minus
1, and then to n minus 2,
and then to n minus
3-- characteristic
of linear algorithms.
Log-linear we're going
to see next time.
Polynomial--
typically quadratic n
squared when we have nested
loops or nested recursive
calls.
I'm looping over something.
Inside of there, I'm
looping over something else
on a size that depends on
the size of the problem.
And then, we just
saw this last one.
Multiple recursive
calls at each level
tends to be characteristic
of exponential.
And as I said, we'd like to
be as high up in this list
as we can, because those are
really nice algorithms to have.
Let me give you one more
example of looking at this,
and then we'll be done.
Fibonacci-- standard
problem, right?
The nth Fibonacci number is
the sum of the previous two
Fibonacci numbers.
This was the example we
saw of multiplying rabbits,
if you like.
Here's an iterative
version of Fibonacci, which
says if n is 0, it's just 0.
If it's 1 is just 1.
Otherwise, I'm going
to set up, initially,
the two previous
Fibonacci numbers.
And then I'm just going
to run through a loop
where I temporarily keep
track of that number.
I move the second previous one
into the last previous one.
I add those two.
That becomes the
second previous number.
And I just keep running
through that loop.
You can go run it.
You see it does the right thing.
What I want to look
at is the complexity.
So that's constant.
That's constant.
That's linear, because the work
inside the loop is constant,
but I'm doing it n times.
So this is nice.
[INAUDIBLE] I should say,
the bottom thing is constant.
The overall algorithm, the
worst case is just order n.
Great.
What about the
recursive version?
For me, this is much nicer code.
It's nice and clean.
It says if n is equal
to 0, fib is 0, 0.
If n is equal to 1, fib of
1-- or the first and second
Fibonacci numbers-- are 0 and 1.
Otherwise, just return
what I get by summing
both of those pieces.
And you can probably
already guess
what the complexity is
going to be here, right?
Because I've now
got two recursive
calls inside of this call.
So one way to think
about it is, if I'm
going to solve the
problem up here,
I've got to solve two
versions of the problem below,
which has got to solve two
versions of the problem below.
And in general, this is going
to be exponential, 2 to the n.
Now you say, wait a minute.
I was paying attention
when this guy was yattering
on a couple of weeks ago.
Honest, I was.
And in fact, what we saw
was that fib isn't balanced
in terms of how it goes, right?
It's not that, on the
right-hand side of the tree,
I have to solve all
of those portions,
because the problem
gets smaller.
Does that change the complexity?
Well, the answer is,
it changes the base,
but it's actually
still exponential.
And if you want to
go look this up,
I'm sure you can find
Wikipedia very quickly.
This actually has a very
cool exponential growth.
It's the golden ratio
to the nth power.
And in fact, I
encourage you to go look
at it in the even more
copious spare time you have.
It's a very cool
proof to see it.
But the bottom line
is, while we can
do a little bit better
than 2 to the n,
it still grows
exponentially with n.
So what do we have?
We've got big O
notation as a way
of talking about comparing
efficiency of algorithms.
What I want you to
see here is that you
ought to be able to begin
to reason about what's
the cost of an
algorithm by recognizing
those common patterns.
I keep saying it, but it's going
to be really valuable to you.
And you should be
able to therefore work
the other direction.
When you're given
a new problem, how
do I get this into a
linear algorithm if I can?
Log-linear, if I can,
would be really great.
But you know, if I
can't, how do I stay away
from exponential algorithms?
And finally, what we're
going to show later on
is that, in fact, there
are some problems that,
as far as we know, are
fundamentally exponential.
And they're
expensive to compute.
The very last
thing is, you might
have decided I was cheating
in a different way.
So I'm using a set of
built-in Python functions.
I'm not going to go
through all of these.
But this is just a
list, for example,
for lists, of what
the complexity
of those built-in functions are.
And if you look through the
list, they kind of make sense.
Indexing, you can go
straight to that point.
Computing the length,
you compute it once,
you've stored it.
Comparison-- order
n, because I've
got to compare all the
elements of the list.
Similarly, to remove
something from the list,
I've got to find where it is
in the list and remove it.
Worst case, that's
going to be order n.
So you can see that these
operations are typically
linear in the size of a list.
These are constant.
For dictionaries,
remember, dictionaries
were this nice thing.
They weren't ordered.
It gave me a power in
terms of storing them.
But as a consequence, some
of the costs then go up.
For a list, indexing, going
to a particular point,
I just go to that
spot and retrieve it.
Indexing into a
dictionary, I have
to find that point in the
dictionary that has the key
and get the value back.
So that's going to be
linear, because I have to,
in principle, walk
all the way down it.
It's a slight misstatement,
as we'll see later on.
A dictionary actually
uses a clever indexing
scheme called a hash.
But in the worst case,
this is going to be linear.
So you see a trade-off.
For dictionaries,
I get more power.
I get more flexibility.
But it comes as a cost.
And so these,
basically, are what
let me reason on
top of the things
I've been doing to
figure out complexity.
And next time, we'll do
the last piece of this
when we look at sorting.
So we'll see you
all on Wednesday.